voyager c'est découvrir de nouvelles
choses tu es dans un des plus beaux
endroits du monde quel problème il peut
bien y avoir j'avais planifié ce voyage
avec mon copain et à la dernière seconde
il est pas venu viens squatter chez moi
c'est gentil mais je veux pas m'imposer
ça va
aller changement de programme je me suis
fait une nouvelle copine je prolonge mon
séjour
ici on va explorer le pays je viens de
me rendre compte que je me suis pas
assise devant un fitcamp depuis au moins
ans tu m'as amené ici pour m'assassiner
au milieu de l'océan personne m'entendra
crier tout se passe tellement mieux
depuis que j'ai décidé de rester
ici et j'ai quelques idées pour le
planning de demain en fait j'ai prévu
une surprise pour demain tout se passe
tellement mieux depuis que j'ai décidé
de rester ici depuis quand tu es timide
toi j'aime pas être sur les
vidéos attends quelqu'un d'autre se
faisait passer pour toi hier il y a
quelqu'un tout se passe tellement mieux
depuis que j'ai décidé de rester
ici
non je vais pas te tuer là tu me déçois
énormément